foreign
[Music]
Ty two my name is Freddie gray and I'll
be presenting this show where we will
talk about cancellation in comedy
I'm joined today delighted to be joined
today by Andrew Doyle the comedian who
has just had a show canceled in capital
letters the capital letters very
dramatic uh it's this is at the
Edinburgh Fringe will you just tell us
the story of this particular
cancellation yes uh it's
um I run a comedy night in London called
comedy Unleashed which is every month
and we decided this year we were going
to take it up to the Edinburgh Fringe we
decided quite late in the day uh so we
weren't in time for The Fringe brochure
or anything like that and all the venues
had gone we managed to get a venue in a
place called Leith on the outskirts of
Edinburgh so it was very much Fringe Of
The Fringe right
um and it was just one night and we were
gonna have a mixed Bill comedy night and
the people on the bill were going to be
Mary Burke Bruce Devlin Alistair
Williams Dominic Frisbee and Graeme
Linehan and Graeme linen of course uh
has proven to be quite a controversial
figure lately for no good reason as far
as I'm concerned uh but he's the writer
of Father Ted The IT Crowd black book so
really really established one of our
best comedy writers one of the most
famous comedy writers we have
um and we were going to do this gig and
because Graham has been canceled
completely by the industry and because
he you know he wrote a musical
adaptation of Father Ted Which hat trick
Productions are holding to Ransom this
is the group that hold the rights
they're not letting it go ahead because
they have capitulated to members of
their staff who are effectively
activists and don't agree with him when
it comes to the trans issue or the
gender identity issue so he's proven to
be controversial within an industry that
has taken a particular ideological line
on these issues so which is one of the
reasons we platform him we always
platform not well we platform him first
and foremost because he's bloody funny
and Brilliant at what he does but
secondarily because we make a point of
of platforming people who have been
canceled so when we advertise this gig
in Leith at the Leith arches on the
poster sort of for a bit of fun we put a
shadow instead of the the person that
said famous canceled surprise comedian
sort of thing bit of anticipation right
um we knew the gig was going to sell out
we didn't have worries about we didn't
need to publicize Graham but I'd always
always said to Graham from the start We
Will We Will publicize you and it came
to a couple of days before the gig and I
I thought well okay we can announce it
now if there is any risk of activists
kicking up a fuss that it's too late now
it's just a couple of days away and I
was completely wrong about that so uh it
was announced on the morning uh
yesterday morning so what was happening
Monday morning and then um
uh by the afternoon in the Leith Arch's
venue had put out an Instagram post
saying that the whole thing was canceled
and as you say they say canceled in
Block capitals they wanted to get the
message across yes they said they they
wouldn't allow Graham's views to violate
their safe it's not safe space but to
say their space it was very dramatic it
was very histrionic yes I think it's
worth reading it out okay A bit because
it uh it is it's sort of interestingly
subliterate and and full of Rage uh
Leith arches uh posted a statement on
Instagram stating the Do Not in capital
letters support this comedian or his
views and he will not be allowed to
perform at our venue and is counseled
from Thursdays
with immediate effect
uh and then he says we are an inclusive
venue and will not allow such fees to
violate our space that's the best
sentence so that's the old inclusive uh
using inclusivity to exclude exactly yes
if it was done deliberately I would
congratulate them for that yeah I fear
not and then of course a number of um
prominent lawyers in Scotland pointed
out that you know they've admitted to
Breaking the Law then they've admitted
to discriminating against someone for a
belief that is protected in law
um and this is puts them on dodgy ground
so they issued a new statement which was
a bit more muted
um still roughly saying the same thing
but saying it doesn't align with their
values which is actually the standard
shibboleth of people who want to cancel
but they don't want to admit that
they've broken the law yes
well can I ask did you buy buy some
delaying the Linehan uh announcement
that he was going to be and he probably
would have been the person that might
have triggered this sort of response to
were you were you slightly fishing for a
reaction were you trying to no no no not
at all I mean in fact I didn't think
there would be one
um ultimately when the venue have since
said that they have a problem with other
members of other people on the bill they
haven't specified who that doesn't
really make sense because they'd had the
posters well well in advance they knew
it was comedy Unleashed they knew what
we do uh the ethos of the club
um
absolutely not fishing for a reaction
because I thought well this is the
Edinburgh Fringe I know we had the
cancellation of Jerry sadowitz last year
but that was after there had already
been a performance and then in that
performance some members of Staff saw it
and got upset and so they canceled the
second night I never thought that they
would cancel preemptively a show uh I
what I thought what would happen is we
might get a few activists turning up on
the night protesting or whatever and I
couldn't be bothered with that that's
really serious I seriously think they
would uh the venue would actually cancel
it
um and it happened so rapidly uh so yeah
I was proven wrong quite quickly
actually but have you found you found
another venue now yeah yeah so we were
determined to put it on you know it's uh
I think it's it's incredibly I mean The
Fringe
has always been subject to complaints
from puritanical groups you know I mean
when was it established roughly 47 1947
something like that and then by the time
you get to the 60s you're getting you
know more sexualized shows uh more
controversial shows and I think from
that point onwards there were always
normally members of the Christian right
protesting even when I started going to
The Fringe uh back in the day that must
have been sort of like early 2000s and
doing shows then uh I'd see the odd
group of Christian protesters with Bible
verses and things talking about the
degeneracy and all the rest of it and
all it is is that those people are have
been reincarnated in a sense these are a
new set of Pharisees that aren't uh
religious but they have their own
religion their own quasi-religion which
is the religion of what I call critical
social justice what most people call the
woke movement uh they're the same
they're the same they have this
precisely the same worldview that Mary
Whitehouse used to have which was that
if the the great unwash the masses are
exposed to popular culture that has
certain messages they will be corrupted
by those messages it's the precise same
thing because if they didn't believe
that they would just simply not buy a
ticket and resolve the situation that
way what the this handful of what I
object to is that there are a handful of
authoritarians who are saying not only
that they don't want to see the show or
that they disapprove of the show which
they are free to do of course they're
free to be as offended and upset as they
like
um but they have decided that in
addition to them not seeing the show
they will prevent anyone else from
seeing the show including a sellout
audience with sold all the tickets and
all of those people have every right to
choose for themselves what shows they go
to see so I felt it was an incumbent on
me and Andy Shaw We Run The the night to
persist with this Graham was very keen
to do so he said he would do it on a
street corner if he had to so there's a
principle at stake at this point at
first we just wanted a fun show now
we're making a point I mean I suppose in
a way though even comedy unleash being
at the fringes is making a point in so
far as we exist in a comedy industry
that hates us they hate the fact that we
exist we are constantly bombarded with
nonsense from Comedians and the
occasional hit piece from magazines like
Vice or whatever it's called
um because they they the idea of a free
thinking comedy night the idea of a
night where we say people might be
offended but that's their issue you know
where we might have subversive Comics
um I mean for when we started we got
lots of comedians saying this is
unnecessary people aren't being canceled
or censored what you're doing we've been
Vindicated of course because so many
comedians have now had shows taken away
from them but in addition to that ever
since we started we've had a steady
stream of emails over the years of
people saying I can't do my material
anywhere else anymore can I come and do
it at your club now if it were the case
uh that self-censorship is not a problem
in the comedy industry why do I keep
getting these emails yeah we as you
suggested it has proved your point uh
because you set up comedy Unleashed was
it four years ago to uh to sort of
escape the what you seem to describe as
sort of suffocating very narrow
Progressive worldview that seems to make
the rules over what is allowed to be
what what you're allowed to joke to
offer another ethos I mean there are
clubs there's a club in London where you
have to sign a contract before you begin
out outlining which topics you cannot
speak about yeah and at that club as
well people on the front row have to
wear green stickers if they consent to
be spoken to by an act now I think
that's nonsense and I think it's
anathema to the art form but I think
they're perfectly free to put on a night
like that and I support their right to
do so and I think if if people want to
go along to that kind of anodyne event
uh and and chuckle along approvingly at
opinions they agree with that they're
perfectly entitled to do them and I
applaud them for it great knock yourself
out but we want to do comedy from a kind
of Comedy literature perspective you
know where we our audiences understand
that comedy can't exist without the
potential to cause offense they all know
that that's a possibility uh audiences
that watch acts on stage and don't
assume that the ACT is making explicit
and literal statements about what they
believe but are in fact telling jokes
you saw last year when Jerry sadowitz
was canceled at the Edinburgh Fringe the
the statement that was put out by the
Pleasants theater trust and bear in mind
this is one of the biggest comedy
Platforms in the world really the
Pleasants one of the main venues at
Edinburgh they said they couldn't
tolerate the opinions that he was
expressing on stage he wasn't expressing
opinions he didn't Express a single
opinion they're called jokes and if the
uh the key figures principal figures
within the comedy industry don't know
what jokes are and they don't I mean
television's the same you know you had
uh the the BBC streaming service has a
version of Faulty Towers the version
that you watch of the episode called the
Germans when you watch that famous
episode there is a scene removed on the
BBC and the reason it's removed is
because there are racial epithets in the
scene and the reason there are racial
epithets in the scene is because they're
coming from the character of the major
who is like an old has been and the show
is mocking him for his reactionary uh
anti-deluvian world view but the people
at the BBC don't understand the joke
they don't understand how Comedy Works
so they've taken the scene out either
that or they have this very patronizing
view that the audience won't understand
how Comedy Works and they feel they need
to protect them but there's there's a
certain inconsistency going on in comedy
isn't it because uh someone like Frankie
Boyle is welcomed uh everywhere and his
jokes
um you know can be very shocking and
offensive you know to a lot of people I
think he's got a bit about uh wanting to
rape and kill Holly Willoughby yeah uh
which um you know I don't think either
of us would mind that someone can make
jokes about that I think that you should
have the freedom to do it but Frankie
Boyle is not canceled no uh well he's
but he has the right opinions I mean but
yeah but yes but he but I mean it's not
the right opinion to want to write rape
and kill Holly Willoughby is it no but
they they recognize that when he says
that he's not being literal he's not
literally expressing what he believes
because yes so they're capable of seeing
they are capable of distinguishing when
they want to think about it for a moment
yeah I mean he you know his show if you
saw his show the last show he did was it
was called New World Order it was very
much
a kind of checklist of all the voguish
uh establishment opinions that are in
currency at the moment yeah um and so
therefore of course they're not going to
complain about Frankie Boyle
um but they will complain about acts
they they don't approve of uh people
like Graham Lincoln his opinions are uh
Beyond The Pale according to um the the
cultural establishment so yeah it is
you're right it's of course it's
inconsistent it's it's horribly
inconsistent but when have they ever
been consistent yes I mean I suppose
what I'm getting at is it's about the
person isn't it not the not the content
and if you're if you're deemed to be a
bad person well that's you know your
comedy can be if Frankie Boyle came out
tomorrow and said there is a difference
between men and women if he came out
tomorrow and said uh you know no human
being has ever changed sex which is true
if he came out tomorrow and said uh
we've got to protect women's rights to
have their own Single Sex spaces or that
children who are likely to grow up gay
uh under gender non-conforming need to
be protected from sterilization and
mutilation by the NHS
um well I don't I think they would
complain about the Hollywood joke at
that point I think that's when they
would start making a noise uh as it
stands he he's been silent on all of
those issues but there is comedy that's
thriving I mean coming in Unleashed
seems to be doing very well uh and there
are now very famous comedians who who
dabble with who who clash with cancel
culture and actually do well out to
benefit from it in a way I mean yeah
more publicity and people side with them
mostly uh yeah well there's firstly the
case that you know most of the comedians
that don't just don't care they joke
about whatever they want they take on
Council culture but they're too big to
cancel people like Dave Chappelle people
like Ricky Gervais brilliant comics and
they they are in that position where
they can do this you can't cancel people
as successful as that yeah um I mean you
can try with Dave Chappelle they were
gathering outside Netflix trying to get
Netflix to cancel one of their most
successful shows that was never going to
happen yes um someone even rushed him on
stage with a knife didn't they so they
there's that
um so yes absolutely so those comedians
can still do that and they do and thank
God they do it's always surprised me
that there are comedians of that stature
who don't uh to go after the obvious the
obvious Target for comedians these days
the people that like I say the Pharisees
you know the idea of not mocking the
prigish uh paternalistic authoritarian
elements of society feels like you're
kind of in dereliction of your job as a
comedian if you leave if you ring fence
them from ridicule but that's a separate
point I guess but yes you're right and
then um the people who it mostly affects
our up-and-coming comedians uh who
basically have started to tailor their
material according according to what
they perceive the industry requires them
to do
um so if you are and of course not all
Comics are naturally subversive um in my
stand-up I'm not uh edgy or
controversial
um and and I think it wouldn't quite
work if I if I if I did that
um but there are a lot of people who are
instinctively they want to subvert they
see something and they want to push
against the grain but in today's climate
they can't and therefore they don't so
we are probably losing all sorts of
incredible talents because they are
having to produce uh just really Bland
um stand up when they could be doing
something more uh innate to the kind of
person that they are I mean I kind of
think um if I were a young stand-up now
coming up through the ranks there's no
way I mean the industry has made it
absolutely clear you've got the comedy
industry website chortle which is
completely ideologically captured and
very intolerant of it's very illiberal
in its nature you've got uh Nika Burns
who was head of the Comedy Awards making
a speech to launch the 2018 Edinburgh
Festival where she said she was looking
forward to Comedy in the new woke world
she said I'm looking forward to these
new woke Comedians and those were her
words not mine she said the woke
movement should be setting the
parameters of what is acceptable to say
on stage now when the one of the top
figures of the comedian industry makes a
speech to launch the largest Comedy
Festival in the world saying that is
what we expect from you that is an edict
from high and it was observed subsequent
to that I don't think it's any
coincidence that subsequent to that
speech
um pretty much no young up and coming
Comics are really subversive in any
serious sense you're not going to get a
kind of Joan Rivers kind of character a
Patrice O'Neill kind of character you
know these people don't exist on the
circuit now very much
and of course it it does exactly what it
shouldn't do which is make comedy
unfunny so it does that you know the
problem with the work movement of course
is that its practitioners are
particularly humorless that sort of part
of yeah you know as all authoritarian
bodies have always been all tyrants hate
to be laughed at yes um so if you are
authoritarian by Nature it's it's it's
very common for you not to have a sense
of humor in addition to that you have
the literal mindedness which I mentioned
earlier that's very very uh common now
um so I often get comments or see
comments when on comedians posts where
where the person is taking it very very
literally yeah
um you know I mean I did a set at comedy
Unleashed where I was mocking the idea
that people thought comedy Unleashed was
racist and I did that by suggesting that
I only set up the club so I could say
racist things and that's and I said this
stuff once and then someone quoted me
unfortunately this ended up in a TV show
on BBC yes and then someone quoted my
lines back at me on Twitter saying look
you've just admitted that you set it up
set up the night to be racist it's there
it is you know if that's the Smoking Gun
and if you don't have a sense of irony
if you can only think of things
literally then I suppose to you those
things on stage are opinions there's no
humor there so therefore what are they
they must be a pin yes and taken out of
context which is the the very important
thing that happens a lot on social media
that you you can be taken out of context
very quickly and a herd mentality can
work against you because somebody has
taken you out well any yeah yeah I mean
exactly so so jokes I mean for instance
this happened with Alfie Brown where
someone found an old uh stand up set
where he used the n-word uh this was
about 10 years ago but it's a stand-up
set he's not going on there and
expressing racist views he's using the
term there's a context to it I don't
even trust watching a clip of a of a a
stand-up uh performance unless I'm there
unless I'm in the room I don't know what
the context is really so I'm very very
mistrustful of that but context is all
important when Joe brand was
investigated by police or when the
police said they were looking into her
because she made a joke about throwing
battery acid at leaders uh political
leaders and she made that joke though on
a radio show called heresy there's your
context the context of the show is it's
about saying abominable things things
that will get you in trouble it's a
common it's a comedian on a comedy show
and the audience are laughing at the
statement
that should have been sufficient for the
police to say why has anyone contacted
us to begin with
do you find that um I mean comedy
Unleashed cancellation has got a big
theme of the of the comedy that you do
yeah uh is there a danger that just as
there's a humanist creeping in uh in
comedy through through progressivism
that in resisting it you yourselves are
becoming a bit too serious and that it
starts to dominate The Comedy I sound
very humorless right now don't I I mean
the thing is when I talk about it uh I I
talk seriously about it I wrote a book
called free speech and why it matters
it's not a single joke in that yeah I'm
quite proud of that
um it's it's entirely uh straight faced
um
so yeah that's that's true but it's not
I don't perceive it to be the job of the
comedian to be funny all the time I find
it very hard when when people say oh
you're a comedian why aren't you making
me laugh well tell me tell me a joke
yeah yeah it's like well I'm not on a
stage at the moment now you know it it
so I think ultimately
I mean I'm quite a serious person and I
talk about things seriously when I when
I'm on stage I'll make you laugh and
that's the difference so so as long as I
don't get start going on stage and
preaching in a humanist way yeah see
that would be my red line uh the risk I
think is that people do that you'll
notice that a lot of the um the sort of
identitarian leftist
um woke comedians stop being funny
because they they start substituting
humor for sermons yes and that you you
know exactly I don't want to drop names
but you know exactly the type of comics
I'm talking about they stand up and they
just say the fashionable opinions and
then they get a round of applause
usually rather than a laugh yes because
people aren't laughing which is an
instinctive response they're applauding
to Signal approval of the opinion
expressed so that to me isn't comedy
really uh that to me is it's something
and you know and I support
I support anyone's right to get up and
preach if they want to be a preacher
that's great even if they want to be a
preacher and call it comedy that's great
you know I'm all for artistic expression
and free expression but I would be very
nervous myself if I started going on
stage and becoming too serious on stage
as a comic then uh yeah I wouldn't be
happy with that it's also uh about a
sort of fake courage isn't it um that a
lot of comedians uh do rants on stage as
though they're saying something very
important energy and very shocking as
though it's a very courageous thing to
do when actually it's almost the
opposite of Courage because it's weird
isn't it because the these opinions that
as I say are fashionable these are the
opinions that will get you booked on uh
BBC panel shows that will get you uh
applaudits that will get you nominated
for awards in Edinburgh yeah uh it's the
opposite of Brave it's the safest thing
you can do you know um and but they like
to think that they are that's the weird
thing about this movement is they think
they are downtrodden they think they're
The Underdogs that's also why it's
really hard to push back against them
you know they are some of the most
powerful people in society they have
prominence in all major institutions be
they public institutions or or
governmental institutions Civic
institutions they're everywhere they're
in the NHS the police Academia you know
I don't think that you can seriously
stand there and say uh that you are a
rebel that you are against the
establishment when all of major
corporations are on your side all of
Hollywood all of Academia the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex like you the if these
people are on your side you are the
establishment
and yet so much of their stick is about
being oppressed you know or about being
the ones brave enough to call out
bigotry in society of course bigotry
best to describe them because the
definition of bigotry is as you know
someone who is intolerant to different
viewpoints but that's them in a nutshell
yeah and Graham Linens uh have you seen
hit the routine that he's going to do no
not particularly I mean you know I've
seen the routines he's done at our club
yeah
because he always does different
material he's you know he's trying to
develop and cultivate different material
at the moment
um he's new to stand up as I say so he's
um he's trying stuff out it wasn't he
was only going to do like 10 minutes on
on stage um it wasn't necessarily going
to be fully polished the point was that
it's a forum for him to try this stuff
out so
but from what I've seen I think he's
brilliant I love his material I love the
way he's doing it and
it's he's just he's a genius so we
should be platforming comedy Geniuses
right and we shouldn't be saying we're
not going to do that in case a couple of
people are upset about it is it is it
about uh you know the denial of
biological reality is that is that what
he jokes about or does he do well so far
he hasn't I mean in the sets I've seen
him do so far he hasn't spoken about it
of course he he can talk about whatever
he wants that's the point um
uh I know that he tweeted out today uh
that he was going to fight this because
he thinks the world it deserves to see
his 10 minutes of unprepared material
about pizza boxes I think that's what he
said uh something along those lines so
you know so he's he's keeping his sense
of humor in the midst of all the lies
that are being told about him in the
midst of all these people bombarding him
online putting up fake screenshots of
things they claim he said that he's
never said I mean it's horrible you know
that's the thing about Graham is you
know part of the reason why so people so
many people have turned against me is
he's quite pugilistic he's quite uh he
goes on the attack but actually he's not
he's going on the defensive what's
happening is he's so isolated yeah like
he's he has had no support from former
friends even friends within the comedy
industry just radio silence across the
board for years have people as people
have smeared him defamed him and I speak
as someone who I mean Graham and I had a
big spat back in the day like about five
years ago he called me alt-right or
something like that so we we you know he
attacked me on Twitter once I remember
I had a whole week of people people
joining in yeah
Freddie you should speak to him about
that because like he did say to me like
if he could go back he said he's they're
like those tweets he said I can't be
sure I was right about anything he said
I was wrong about so much yeah that uh
you know he's embarrassed he says he's
embarrassed by it so I think um well all
social media is embarrassing it is it is
but you know the fact that he
sometimes he's perceived to be a
antagonistic well I would be too if I'd
if I had been at the top of my career
and I've been completely canceled from
it I can't get working anymore it get
work anymore if I've got activists
calling the police if I've got the
police visiting me for something I've
said online as it happened with graham
if I've got uh people who've sent
threats uh uh or continually threatening
legal action I might get a bit
pugilistic too yeah well on that note
Andrew I think we'll end it there but
I'm very glad to hear the show has not
been not entirely canceled and it will
be no it's going ahead we're going to do
it there we go maybe cancel the country
isn't real uh well I'm afraid it is
um but we're going to push back against
it it is that was a facetious joke it
was but I didn't get it you see he's
getting little minded
thank you Andrew
[Music]